fall weather is officially here here in
southern nevada and
it is cold outside we have team coverage
for you tonight
sally is keeping an eye on the
temperatures and that wind but first
let's head out to 8 news now reporter
madison kimbrough who's at the base of
mount charleston
where people saw some snow out there
madison
yes hey sasha this is pretty
unbelievable you can kind of see behind
me here
but we are at mount charleston here in
clark county and it is currently 27
degrees
i got to tell you i just moved to nevada
a couple weeks ago and this is
definitely not what i expected
just being about 45 minutes from las
vegas now take a look at the video that
we shot earlier where you can really see
the extent
of the snow this is the major snowfall
of the year and season
and people were out and took advantage
metro police was currently assisting
drivers directing them
the other way it was too icy for cars to
go up the mountain
now snow tires and chains were required
earlier we spoke to some people who
drove up to enjoy the snowy conditions
take a listen it's been a hot summer
obviously and just something to do and
yesterday was a good day
and we're happy and here we are in the
snow it's fun
tasty and well you can go sledding with
it
and that's the best part
as you can see people were really
enjoying themselves out here like he
said the snow was
very tasty and people were just really
making sure to be careful if you do
decide to take part in the snowy
conditions tonight
please be careful and make sure you
bring the proper snow and vehicle
equipment
live from mount charleston madison
kimbrough 8 news now